ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement vient de présenter sa
réforme des retraites et le moins que
l'on puisse dire et que les femmes
pourraient être les grandes perdantes
des mesures à venir l'étude d'impact le
démontre clairement elles devront
travailler en moyenne 7 mois de plus
alors que les hommes ne seront astreints
à 5 mois supplémentaires en outre de
nombreuses femmes pouvaient partir dès
62 ans à taux plein grâce au trimestre à
qui lors de la naissance de leurs
enfants avec votre réforme elles devront
travailler deux ans de plus pour
atteindre le nouvel âge légal de 64 ans
et perdront le bénéfice de cette
bonification vous aurez beau jeu de
souligner qu'en travaillant plus
longtemps et bénéficieront d'une
retraite de revaloriser vous ne
manquerez pas de rappeler également
quels seront les premières bénéficiaires
de la hausse au minimum de la pension du
minimum de pension mais de quelle
retraite parlons-nous vous n'ignorez pas
que la retraite des femmes et de 40%
inférieure à celle des hommes parce
qu'elles sont les premières victimes des
inégalités salariales
vous ne pouvez ignorer non plus quelles
ont des carrières fréquemment
interrompues par des maternités qui
réduisent la durée de cotisations et
font d'elle les plus touchées par la
décote dans ces conditions il est
indispensable de compenser les forces
supplémentaires demandées aux femmes de
mieux en prendre en compte leur
maternité car une réforme des retraites
par répartition ne peut se désintéresser
de la politique familiale et d'avancer
l'âge de la décote à ce stade du projet
loi et avant les discussions
parlementaires ces mesures nous
paraissent plus équitables que
l'allongement de la durée de vie active
pour améliorer le taux de pension
êtes-vous prêt monsieur le ministre à
corriger ces injustices qui concernent
les femmes et que notre groupe a déjà
pointé à plusieurs reprises sur un sujet
aussi grave nous aurons à cœur de
trouver en la majorité sénatoriale comme
à notre habitude une solution de
compromis acceptable par tous je vous
remercie pour votre réponse